-Welcome.
-Did I sit too soon?
-No, that was perfect.
Thank you.
Just like Jim,
I met you at the Emmys,
or I saw you at the Emmys.
We had met before.
Did you have a first time --
Congrats on the nomination,
first of all.
-Thank you as well.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, it was my first
big Emmy experience.
-It was your first
Emmy experience.
-I´ve been to
the creative arts Emmys.
But this one, it´s the mondo.
-This is the real D.
-It´s the real -- the real D.
-Yeah.
-And I think I almost bumped
into you
or knocked you over.
-No, no, not at all.
-It was salmon swimming
upstream, guys.
-There was a lot of people.
-There was a lot going on.
Yeah, but it was really fun
until we had to go
and take the pictures.
And I was like, "Ann Dowd,
you go in front of me.
And I love her.
And she´s lovely.
-She was wonderful, won an Emmy.
Fantastic. Well-deserved.
-Well-deserved.
But it´s just --
the people that you revere
and that you see and you
respect, and you´re like,
"I am two feet in front of them
or feeling their hot breath
on my neck, and that´s okay."
-Yes.
-So, it´s great.
-Oh, my God, all my favorites
and now we´re a little sweaty.
And it´s a little hot.
And I don´t want to smell them.
-Right. And we´re all equal.
-But I will say
if there was the one --
The biggest star there,
for my money, was Oprah.
And you could tell everybody
wants to
kind of rub elbows with Oprah.
Everyone wants to say hello.
You kind of hit the jackpot.
You had already won the Emmys
because you had
lunch with Oprah.
-I did.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, and she --
-Yeah.
-And this didn´t happen by
coincidence. She reached out.
-No, it was on purpose.
-She called you?
-Yeah. She called me,
and I literally thought
I was being punk´d.
-I know that "Punk´d"
is not on anymore.
But I was like,
"is this Ashton?"
-If you brought "Punk´d" back,
you would do it for that.
-For sure.
Let´s punk Chrissy Metz,
thinking that Oprah called her.
But yes, she just -- gratefully,
called me and asked me to lunch.
And it was so lovely.
Milo -- Sterling and I were
sitting next to each other.
And then Milo and Ron,
and then of course
Susan and Chris and Mandy
were on the other side.
But Oprah was, like, the middle.
So we´re like, "Are you on the
right or left of Oprah?"
Right,
´cause that´s how it goes.
-Sure.
-Right.
So, yes,
the lunch was really lovely.
-How quickly into
a lunch with Oprah
are you inspired in a way
that changes your life forever?
-You´re not joking.
About two seconds.
-Really?
-When she says "Hello, Chrissy."
I was like, "Okay. Okay."
And then I hug her and I´m like,
wow, your home is so beautiful,
and she stopped for a second
and she said,
"You know what? It is."
And it seems a little,
you´re like, "What?"
You might think
it´s pretentious.
But it´s the most beautiful
thing because we don´t ever
relish and enjoy what we´ve
worked really hard for.
And I thought that was so
beautiful that she stopped
and she just was like,
thank you for --
you know, thanking me
for working really hard.
And I think that -- We all need
to do that more often.
-That´s so great.
-So yeah, .2 seconds.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, for sure.
-And that´s --
I think when that was over,
she said, "Oh, I´ve lost a step.
I´m usually -- I´m usually
a little faster."
But this is -- this really
speaks to the crazy difference
in your show between year one
and year two,
which is obviously,
last year around this time,
you guys were
about to be married.
You´d been working on the show.
You knew you had
something special.
But now, you are at "lunch with
Oprah" level as a cast.
How has it felt --
-Where do I go from here?
Is that what you´re asking?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I guess,
in the way that Oprah
is appreciating her house,
are you guys all appreciating
where you´re at as a show?
-Oh, for sure.
I mean, last season, we were
like, "Please, dear God.
Please.
Please somebody watch the show.
I really hope you love it as
much as we love making it."
And now, you know,
I cry with people in bathrooms
and in the chip aisle
at the grocery store.
And so I´m like, "Okay, I think
we´re reaching people,"
which is so amazing
´cause that´s what everybody
wants to do with their art.
-Do you ever,
even with all the success,
do you want to go back to a time
where you didn´t have to cry
with people in the bathroom?
Or is it worth it?
Is it worth the trade-off?
-It´s totally worth it.
-Oh, good.
-And I love to cry, so...
-Okay, good.
-It actually works out.
-There are a lot of things,
a lot of elements of
the show I love.
Personally, my favorite element
is that you´re a Steelers fan.
-Stillers.
-No, I didn´t know that you
knew, but that´s Stillers.
-Oh, Pittsburghese.
-Yeah, Pittsburghese.
-Oh, I studied up on it.
-That´s good.
-I´m not great at it.
-That´s all right.
-But I know it exists.
-But Stillers was -- that´s,
like, that´s level two at least.
-Oh, good.
But you -- you did not have a
connection to that beforehand?
-No. I mean, I grew up
in the South where, you know,
football is a religion, right?
-Yeah.
-So I love football.
But I have a lot of friends or
gentlemen who prefer gentlemen
so they don´t really watch
sports.
-Gotcha.
-Right?
[ Laughter ]
It´s fine, ´cause we do other
things together, which is great.
But when I go home,
I get to watch football
And I get to watch sports
with my family.
But I did love the Stillers when
I was younger, which is bizarre,
´cause I had no connection
to them.
-Uh-huh.
They´re a loveable team.
-They´re a loveable team.
-I would imagine that Pittsburgh
has embraced the show
to a level that they probably
don´t usually embrace other
shows.
-Yes.
And I think that we hopefully,
get to have a little trip there,
maybe this season.
That would be super cool.
-It´s really fun, and it´s
a beautiful place to go.
And you will really enjoy it.
And I just got to say
congratulations on the show,
Chrissy.
It´s so wonderful.
-So grateful.
-And just such a delight to talk
to you.
-Thank you.